good morning everyone and thank you for
coming out I know there are a lot of hot
talks at 10 45 so I'm grateful that
you've ended up in here instead of
Elsewhere my name is Alice Leach I'm a
data engineer at whatnot and for some
reason I chose to title this extreme
self-service I think I may regret it now
but we're going to talk about the rock
and roll version of self-service that we
have tried our best to implement at
whatnot so it can be helpful to
understand the kind of data problems
that we're facing
um so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about what not itself what not is a live
stream shopping platform so what that
means is we have sellers who go live and
buyers can bid on their products live on
the application
um it's the fastest growing Marketplace
in the US for two years in a row and we
sell in about 80 probably more than that
even as I speak product categories right
now so
growth is awesome and we're very lucky
to be growing but it can lead to
challenges so with growth comes lots and
lots and lots of data needs and we're a
very small data team so
um we have always ascribed to the kind
of self-service nature of a data
platform to make sure everyone gets what
they need as fast as possible
and so we were maintaining what I would
would call a regular again the
adjectives Beyond me but a regular
self-service platform so people were
accessing data they were running queries
building dashboards generating reports
and what we were finding where we were
receiving more and more and more and
more ad hoc requests to the data
Engineers can you build me this new data
set can you productionize this report
that I built I want it to be CEO worthy
and always always kind of accurate
um they wanted to generate new data and
immediately have it in the snowflake
database and be able to push data out to
the the tools that they were using kind
of up front and so we began to ask
ourselves how can we allow people to do
this immediately without us interfering
if you will how can we stay out of that
way
and the three ways we've tried to do
this are building community in SQL
literacy establishing and sharing best
practices and building robust guardrails
I'm going to go into each of these but
before I do so it's really really
important to understand who is actually
using your data platform before you
start launching into trying to get them
to do things by themselves
um so while all of our users are unique
and special we can typically associate
them with one of three buckets and so
they're down on the left hand side there
so we have our business stakeholders
this could be you know the head of our
Lego category and what she wants to know
is is that category successful is it
growing every day how many people have
bought in that category how many sellers
do they have have they churned anyone in
the last 24 hours so that's a business
stakeholder and they need to know what's
going on in their Zone in great detail
we also have the kind of analytics and
machine learning team persona they are
more interested in kind of deeper
questions so perhaps our machine
learning team might want to know what
order they they rank the feeds in today
and they might want to build a model to
do that our analytics team might be
interested in customer engagement across
the platform who's clicking where when
and why are people interacting with a
new feature similarly our software
Engineers who build the features
themselves they might want to know is
their new feature being adopted they
might be building up a seller dashboard
they may need access to that data
quickly and with low latency
and
while they don't necessarily map
one-to-one we found that with those
personas with those consumers we were
able to kind of bucket them into three
goals for us to have as Constructors as
people who are building their own and
and meeting their own data needs so with
that in mind we have our data Insight
developers um they are generating data
assets they're building dashboards that
are production level and they're using
tools like snowflake Sigma and Retail
and they need to be intimately familiar
with SQL we also have our data product
developers these are people who might be
building out new data sets they're
people who might be building machine
learning models
um they need to know DBT they need to
interact with our event schema registry
and we would say that that group of
people need to have advanced SQL skills
and here with Advanced SQL I'm kind of
talking about largely efficiency can
they make a table that doesn't just give
them the data that they need but it
gives it them gives it to them without
the query taking 12 hours in our data
warehouse
so the last thing the last Persona if
you will that we wanted from a data
Constructor was a pipeline developer
if someone generates a new table in our
main backend can they get it through to
snowflake immediately and without too
many issues
so if I have all these data Constructors
you might ask what what the hell is the
data engineering team doing if everyone
can do it themselves and I wish the
answer was taking a nap but
unfortunately it's not and what I think
the data team's role is it what not is
to Define and minimize the interactive
surfaces that these Constructors are
using
and then unblock users completely on
those surfaces so they can do everything
as quickly as possible and with ease and
clear definition
so now we know who's doing it and what
we want them to be doing and we can look
a bit closer at how we chose to do that
so the first thing that you might notice
is at least two of these personas need
to be intimately familiar with SQL
so the first thing we wanted to do
um was build out a community of data
users and encourage SQL literacy across
the entirety of our company
so the first thing that I think that you
need to do that is have executive
support
and we are extremely lucky that our
Executives thoroughly believe that
anyone anyone in our company can write
SQL we give immediate read-only access
to Snowflake and we expect anyone who
arrives
to write a SQL query within that first
week
so how do we do that well we do need to
provide some educational content here to
encourage upskilling you'll see at the
left hand side of the screen we have a
learning SQL course available through
our looms and slab
and anyone is available to immediately
head in and get a beginner's crash
course into SQL along to kind of more
advanced your window functions available
there immediately we also hold office
hours to answer any questions we have a
bank of common SQL queries that you can
just copy and paste if you're in a
department that uses that one query to
obtain data and we try and send out
weekly data announcements just to keep
us in people's mind constantly
so as a case study
it can be useful to hear like a specific
example and so one of the things that we
did to try and keep us fresh in people's
minds was a month-long initiative called
back to school
and um what we did was much like the
email marketers that we all know and
love is we spammed people with SQL
queries
um so everyone on the data team took a
day of the month
um and we ended up with three days each
and we sent out a sequel tip of the day
it was usually something we were working
on ourselves so it didn't take too long
to do
um and we were able to just keep fresh
in people's minds who we were and uh
what kind of questions they could be
answering this week or
so the next thing that we chose to do to
try and upskill and
keep people building our data products
as we introduce best practices
and the one thing I would say to
everyone there is lead by example
you can't make people do anything I
learned that as a high school teacher
and it is also true in a large company
or a small company so but what you can
do is you can lead by example and you
can make it as easy as possible for
people to follow your example
so with that in mind we try and provide
slas for everything that we do we built
out a core data Mart using the kind of
SQL that we would hope other people use
so we have that in a DBT GitHub repo so
everyone can see it and we try and
provide utilities and macros wherever
possible so people can use functions
that already exist or macros already
exist to generate things that they might
need to do every day
the thing that we did and Zach will be
talking about later today my colleague
over them
um is we tried to streamline schema
changes as much as possible so anytime
that a software engineer created a new
table or added a new event
um we can propagate that change all the
way through to the data warehouse as
easily as possible with them only
interacting with the event schema
registry surface
the other thing that we try to provide
is templates and documentation so we
have slab and we provide Wikipedia kind
of style articles about our data
products and how to's wherever possible
we also keep an archive of example PRS
lots of people have done things already
so we're able to use those examples to
show perhaps how we would want them to
be done again
the last thing is we encourage as far as
possible everyone to use observability
and testing so so we have opt-in
defaults would you like alerting yes
here are the suite of tests that we're
going to add and we also use slack-based
alerting everyone's in slack all day
anyway it might as well be the place
that we send data alerts to them
the last thing that I would say when it
comes to best practices is as a data
team we want to own as little as
possible so while it would be lovely if
I could look after all 900 tables in our
DBT Reaper that is not a physical
possibility but we do need to know who
owns them and how to contact them
okay with that in mind here's a quick
case study that we use for our best
practices we recently went International
you need to convert currencies there are
a lot of ways to get that wrong I met
some of them
so what we did was we provided a macro
in DBT so that all you have to do is
give it the list of columns that you
want to convert to US Dollars and it
will do it for you
the last thing that I wanted to touch on
was robust guard rails
again we can't make people do what we
want them to do but we can try and stop
them from doing what we really really
don't want them to do
so
the biggest thing that I would say on
this slide is CI CD you really want a
robust cicd process in every repo that
you have we use a combination of
pre-commiting and Stage testing and to
try and avoid things getting pushed into
our main production level services that
create issues the other thing that I
think we found really powerful is setup
and access so making it very very very
easy for a developer to start
interacting with the surface that we've
chosen them to interact with whether
that be the event schema registry or the
DBT repo and that's done by using
combination of make files and then
infrastructures code and single sign-on
so we use OCTA for access
um maintenance wise again we can't own
everything
um so it's become very important with
ownership to have a team tag and a team
tag will direct alerting immediately to
a slack Channel and allow us to notify
people when things that go wrong are
going wrong instead of trying to fix it
ourselves the last thing to touch on is
cleanup when you let people develop
whatever they want
they abandon it
so we had a lot a lot a lot of issues
with dead tables and so we generated
um a cleanup process that goes through
Snowflake and deletes anything that no
longer has an owner or hasn't been used
in greater than 30 days
as an example I want to give you an
overview of the process that we're
currently using for CI CD and the DBT
Ripper we have about 50 developers in
the DBT repo and we average about 10
pull requests a day
so what goes on here is a PR can be
created when it's marked ready for
review we're going to immediately merge
the main branch into that uh
PR we're going to learn the files and
then we're going to in parallel run a
stage run
and a pre-commit equivalent we use DBT
checkpoint for that
then we send the results to the pr
um a code reviewer will take a look if
it's approved we can go ahead and merge
the pr and then we will run a job on
merge a db2 compile and use that to
compare to the next CI run and to allow
us to stay as up to date as possible
so what are we doing in the future well
we really need to take another look at
our continuous deployment procedure it
takes too long people are frustrated by
that we also need to work on modularity
we have a lot of interdependent models
which we would really prefer to be
separate and we need to keep a better
eye on our query monitoring so
preventing those 12 hour queries from
creeping into our projects as a quick
takeaway
I would treat your data platform like a
theme park Disney World if you will
everybody is welcome we have guard rails
we don't have Gates keep the line shut
keep the rides running have fun and be
nice thank you
[Music]